Maupassant didn't care much for the Eiffel Tower. And he didn't care for the food at the restaurant in the Eiffel Tower. But he ate lunch at the restaurant in the Eiffel Tower all the time. "It is the only place in Paris," he used to say, "where I don't have to see it." That is exactly how I feel about my job. I come into work days. I come into work weekends. I stay late at night at work. At least if I'm here, I think, I'm not out worrying about all the things I'm supposed to be doing when I get here.
莫泊桑不太喜欢埃菲尔铁塔。他也不喜欢埃菲尔铁塔里那家餐厅的食物。但他却总是去那里吃午餐。他过去常说：“这是巴黎唯一一个我不用看到它的地方。”这正是我对自己工作的感受。我平时上班，周末也上班。我晚上还要加班。我想，至少如果我在这里，我就不会在外面担心我本该在上班时做的事情。
My dad used to work days and weekends and nights when I was a kid. Now, some Saturdays, he calls me up. I'm at the office. He's at the office. A couple weeks ago, I realized two things about my job, my job producing this radio show, this one right here that you're listening to. I realized that every week as I come to grips with the fact of having to actually do the show, I go through the five stages that Elizabeth Kubler Ross says you go through to come to grips with death. Do you remember the stages? Denial, anger, bargaining, depression and acceptance. That was the first thing I realized.
我小时候，我爸爸总是没日没夜、周末也不停地工作。现在，有时候周六他会打电话给我。我在办公室。他在办公室。几周前，我意识到关于我工作的两件事，也就是制作这档电台节目的工作，正是你们现在听的这档。我意识到，每周当我不得不面对必须做这档节目的事实时，我都会经历伊丽莎白·库伯勒·罗斯所说的面对死亡时会经历的五个阶段。还记得这些阶段吗？否认、愤怒、讨价还价、抑郁和接受。这是我意识到的第一件事。
The second thing I realized was that if I'm having these feelings, I'm spending way too much time at my job. You know, I'm not here to talk about me though. I'm here to talk about you. Our show today, it's all about you. You, you work too hard. You spend too many hours at work. You spend too many hours thinking about work. And if you don't have a job, you spend too many useless hours thinking about that.
我意识到的第二件事是，如果我有这些感觉，说明我把太多的时间花在工作上了。不过，我来这里不是为了谈论我自己。我是来谈论你们的。我们今天的节目，全都是关于你们的。你们，你们工作太辛苦了。你们花了太多的时间在工作上。你们花了太多的时间在思考工作上。如果你们没有工作，你们又花了太多无用的时间在思考这件事上。
Today's show, The Job That Takes Over Your Life.
今天的节目主题是：占据你生活的工作。
Act One, a guy who interviews sick people until he comes to believe that he is sick.
第一幕，一个人采访病人，直到他开始认为自己也病了。
Act Two, some teenagers who think they're signing up to be in a play find out they're joining a sort of cult instead.
第二幕，一些青少年以为自己报名参加了一出戏，结果发现他们加入了一个类似邪教的组织。
Act Three, guys who thrown in the slammer simply because they don't want to work in unsafe conditions.
第三幕，一些人仅仅因为不想在不安全的环境下工作就被投入了监狱。
Act Four, let's not even go into what's in Act Four right now.
第四幕，我们暂时先不讨论第四幕的内容。
Act One.
第一幕。
I was hired to interview men and women in the state of Utah who receive Medicaid support for treatment of mental illnesses generally diagnosed as schizophrenia.
我被雇佣去采访犹他州那些领取医疗补助以治疗通常被诊断为精神分裂症的精神疾病的男女患者。
That's Scott Carrier, who's had an on again, off again, career as a radio reporter in Salt Lake City. He was hired for this interviewing job because the director of the research project heard some of his radio stories and thought he was a good interviewer, somebody who knew how to listen. They taught Scott how to administer this test which measured mental health. It was 100 questions, each of which was scored on a scale of one to seven. It took an hour to give the test. Scott was paid $30 for each test he gave. The people he gave the test to got $5.
那是斯科特·卡里尔，他曾在盐湖城做过一段时间的电台记者，事业起起伏伏。他被雇来做这份采访工作，是因为该研究项目的负责人听了他的一些广播故事，认为他是一位优秀的采访者，是一个懂得如何倾听的人。他们教斯科特如何进行这项评估心理健康的测试。测试共有100个问题，每个问题按一到七分评分。测试需要花费一个小时。斯科特每进行一次测试可获得30美元报酬。接受他测试的人则会得到5美元。
I had little understanding of schizophrenia before I began, and I have little more understanding now. I took the job because I had no other. I took the job because I just quit my steady job, my professional job, after realizing that what I wanted more than anything was to put my boss on the floor and stand on his throat and watch him gag. Then my wife moved out, took the kids and everything. She said, "I've thought about it, and I really think it's the best thing for me at this time in my life."
在开始之前，我对精神分裂症知之甚少，现在也并没有多了解多少。我接这份工作是因为我没有别的选择。我接这份工作是因为我刚刚辞去了稳定的职业工作，当时我意识到，我最想做的事情就是把我的老板按在地上，站在他的喉咙上看着他窒息。后来我妻子搬走了，带走了孩子和所有东西。她说：“我已经考虑过了，我真的认为这对我现阶段的生活来说是最好的选择。”
And so I took the job interviewing schizophrenics because it was offered to me, and because it was all there seemed to be. And it seemed somehow predestined, a karmic response that could not be avoided. It would only be temporary, something to get through the summer. And I was told that they needed someone willing to drive around the state, through the small towns searching out individuals who were often transient and prone to hiding. I like to drive. I like to travel, and I like the idea of pursuit. So I took the job and did the job, and my life will never be the same.
于是我接受了这份采访精神分裂症患者的工作，因为这是给我的机会，而且似乎也只有这些选择了。这似乎是命中注定的，是一种无法避免的业力回应。这只会是暂时的，只是为了度过这个夏天。有人告诉我，他们需要一个愿意开车环绕全州，穿过那些小镇，去寻找那些经常漂泊不定且容易躲藏的人。我喜欢开车。我喜欢旅行，而且我喜欢追求的感觉。所以我接了这份工作，做了这份工作，我的生活将永远改变。
The patient is 21 years old and has lived with his parents since his discharge from the Army. He has no friends, no recreational activities and no social life. He spends his time writing and reading, but these activities do not give him any pleasure. He has lost weight, has general anxiety and loss of libido and occasional feelings of unreality. He is worried about his unpredictable behavior. For example, getting down on all fours and chewing the grass because he was thinking what it would be like to be a cow.
患者21岁，自从从军队退伍后一直和父母住在一起。他没有朋友，没有娱乐活动，也没有社交生活。他把时间花在写作和阅读上，但这些活动并没有给他带来任何快乐。他体重减轻了，有普遍性的焦虑，性欲减退，并偶尔有不真实感。他担心自己不可预测的行为。例如，四肢着地去啃草，因为他在想当一头牛是什么感觉。
The patient is 25 years old and believes that she is the devil and therefore responsible for all the evil in the world. She has not been out of her house for seven days and only comes down from her room for meals. A few days ago, her mother walked into her room and found her crying. She asked her mother what was the most painful punishment that one human being could inflict upon another. The mother tried to get the reason for this question, and her daughter mumbled something about the devil having to be punished for the benefit of humanity, something about having to die for his sins. When the mother asked her if she still thought she was the devil, she answered, "Let's not get into that again. It only upsets you, and you don't believe me anyway, even when the evidence is all around you, plain for you to see."
患者25岁，相信自己是魔鬼，因此应对世界上所有的邪恶负责。她已经七天没有出过家门，只有吃饭时才从楼上的房间下来。几天前，她母亲走进房间发现她在哭。她问母亲，人类能施加于同类的最痛苦的惩罚是什么。母亲试图弄清她问这个问题的原因，女儿嘟囔着说魔鬼必须为了人类的利益受到惩罚，还说为了他的罪孽必须去死。当母亲问她是否仍然认为自己是魔鬼时，她回答道：“我们别再谈这个了。这只会让你难过，而且你反正也不相信我，即使证据就在你周围，明明摆在那里让你看。”
The people I interview are all so sad, so lonely with such thin souls, like ghosts and demons have invaded their hearts and are sucking their souls dry. A person's soul should be like an ocean, but a schizophrenic's soul is like a pool of rain in a parking lot. They suffer, and they are completely alone in their suffering. And there's nothing I can do, nothing anyone can do, to bring them back. I come home at night and cry. I sob like a three-year-old.
我采访的人都那么悲伤，那么孤独，灵魂那么薄弱，就好像鬼魂和恶魔侵入了他们的内心，把他们的灵魂吸干了。一个人的灵魂本该像海洋，但精神分裂症患者的灵魂就像停车场里的一潭雨水。他们受苦，而且在他们的痛苦中完全孤独。我什么也做不了，谁也做不了，无法让他们恢复。我晚上回到家就会哭泣。我像个三岁的孩子一样抽泣。
Today, halfway through an interview with a man in Tooele, he says "I have a crystal in my pouch. Do you want to see it?" I say "OK," and he takes it out, a normal crystal the size of a large paper clip. And he says, "I can look through this, and it will tell me whether you're a good person or a bad person. What do you want me to do? Do you want me to look through it or not?" My first thought is to say, "Do you want to go on with the interview? Maybe when we're done, you can look through the crystal."
今天，在图埃勒采访一个男人时，采访进行到一半，他说：“我的小袋子里有一块水晶。你想看看吗？”我说“好的”，他把它拿了出来，那是一块普通的水晶，大小和回形针差不多。他说：“我可以透过它看，它会告诉我你是一个好人还是坏人。你想让我怎么做？你想让我透过它看吗？”我的第一反应是说：“你想继续采访吗？也许等我们做完后，你可以透过水晶看看。”
But then, I realized that he's really asking me to take his test, just like I'm asking him to take mine. I come into his house, I ask him very personal questions, and I expect him to answer honestly. And why should he? So I say, "OK, go ahead." And he puts the crystal up to his eye, turns it clockwise and counterclockwise, back and forth, squinting, looking me up and down. And he says, "I can't tell for sure. I'm going to have to read your mind. Here, take my hand."
但后来，我意识到他其实是请求我接受他的测试，就像我要求他接受我的测试一样。我走进他的家，问他非常私人的问题，并期望他诚实地回答。他为什么要这样做呢？所以我说：“好的，来吧。”他把水晶放在眼睛前，顺时针转动，再逆时针转动，来回移动，眯着眼睛，上下打量着我。他说：“我不能确定。我得读取你的思想。来，握住我的手。”
He holds out his right hand with the crystal resting in the palm. I take his hand, and he puts his left hand over mine and squeezes it tight and shakes it and goes into a small spasm. The he lets go, and sits back like he's exhausted. He asks me if I felt anything, and I say, "Maybe a little." And he says, "I sent you a message. I put it in your mind. I told you what is wrong with me."
他伸出右手，水晶停在手心里。我握住他的手，他把左手盖在我的手上，紧紧地捏住，摇晃着，然后陷入了一阵小小的痉挛。接着他松开手，瘫坐在后面，就像筋疲力尽一样。他问我有没有感觉到什么，我说：“也许有一点。”他说：“我给你发了一条信息。我把它放进你的脑子里了。我告诉你我出了什么问题。”
I'm not supposed to figure out what's wrong with these people. I'm just supposed to ask the questions and score the answers from one to seven. This is partly because I'm not a doctor and might get something going that I wouldn't know how to contain. But it's mainly because my supervisors want clean data. They want all the people asking the questions to be doing it in the same way. I'm not supposed to get emotional. I'm not supposed to let the patient get emotional. The therapy part of the county mental health system is in another department. I wouldn't even know what number to call, and I've been told more than once not to worry about it. I should never have let him take the crystal out of his pouch.
我不应该去弄明白这些人出了什么问题。我只是被要求问问题，并给答案打一到七分。这部分是因为我不是医生，可能会引发一些我不知道如何处理的问题。但主要是因为我的上司想要干净的数据。他们希望所有问问题的人都以同样的方式进行。我不应该变得情绪化。我不应该让病人变得情绪化。县心理健康系统的治疗部分在另一个部门。我甚至不知道该打哪个号码，而且我不止一次被告知不要担心这些。我真不该让他把水晶从袋子里拿出来。
I drove around all day trying to find a Navajo man. He lives very close to the Four Corners, the cross where Utah, Colorado, New Mexico and Arizona meet. It's all dirt roads, a house every five miles or so, no addresses, no phones. I stop at every house and knock on the door, but either nobody's home, or nobody will answer. I flag down every car that passes and ask directions, and the people offer complicated directions that I follow as best as possible, sometimes driving for 20 or 30 miles. But it's always the wrong place, or nobody's home, or there just isn't a house there at all.
我开车开了一整天，试图找到一名纳瓦霍男人。他住在非常靠近四角纪念碑的地方，那是犹他州、科罗拉多州、新墨西哥州和亚利桑那州交汇的十字路口。那里全是土路，每五英里左右才有一户人家，没有地址，没有电话。我在每一户人家停下来敲门，但要么没人，要么没人应答。我拦下每一辆经过的车问路，人们给出了复杂的路线，我尽可能地跟着走，有时开了二三十英里。但要么地点不对，要么没人，或者根本就没有房子。
Driving around, I think about how I have some of the same problems as the people I interview. I'm angry, depressed, prone to paranoid delusions, and I worry a lot. Up to now, I thought these were common problems, and that I was more or less able to control them. But now, I don't know. I feel like I'm just faking it. Eventually, late in the afternoon, I find the man, or at least I think he's the man. I'm a third of the way through the test before I realize he's not the right guy.
开车的时候，我想到我也有一些和采访对象一样的问题。我愤怒、沮丧、容易产生偏执的妄想，而且我很担心。到目前为止，我以为这些是常见的问题，我或多或少能够控制它们。但现在，我不知道了。我觉得我只是在装模作样。最后，在下午晚些时候，我找到了那个人，或者说至少我以为是那个人。我做完三分之一的测试后才意识到他不是那个人。
"When was your last visit to a mental health clinic?" "I don't go to the clinic." "When did you last see a doctor?" "I don't have a doctor." "Do you blame yourself for anything you've done or not done?" "No." "Have you felt more self-confident than usual?" "No." "Have you heard voices or other things that weren't there, or that other people couldn't hear, or have seen things that weren't there?" And he says, "I think you want to talk to my son." And I ask him what his son's name is, and he says, "Same as mine."
“你上次去心理健康诊所是什么时候？”“我不去诊所。”“你上次看医生是什么时候？”“我没有医生。”“你是否为你做过或没做过的事情责备自己？”“没有。”“你是否比平时感到更自信？”“没有。”“你是否听到过不存在的声音或其他东西，或者别人听不见的东西，或者看到过不存在的东西？”他说：“我想你要找的是我儿子。”我问他儿子叫什么名字，他说：“和我的一样。”
I come back the next morning and interview the son in the kitchen. They make coffee for me on a propane camp stove as the house has no electricity. The son is 19 years old, a good looking kid, tall, healthy, says he used to run cross country in high school. He seems to be fine, but as I go through the questions, he starts to fix his eyes on mine, a direct, almost hypnotic stare straight into my head like he's trying to pull me in and trap me. I try to look back, to look just as deeply into his mind, but it's like looking into a cave.
第二天早上我又回来，在厨房里采访了他儿子。他们用丙烷露营炉为我煮咖啡，因为房子里没有电。儿子19岁，是个长得不错的孩子，高大、健康，说他在高中时曾经参加过越野跑。他看起来没问题，但当我进行到这些问题时，他开始死死盯着我的眼睛，一种直接的、几乎是催眠般的凝视，直入我的脑海，好像他想把我拉进去并困住我。我试着回视，试着同样深邃地看进他的内心，但这就像看进了一个洞穴。
He says he hears voices, satanic voices, and that he worries a lot about his shoes, that they're not the right kind, not the kind he sees on MTV. I can't tell if he's sick, or if he's just trying to torture me. And I drive away thinking, I don't know anything about this disease, that I know even less than when I started. I spent two days driving around and I made $30. And I feel really, really, tired.
他说他听到了声音，撒旦的声音，他非常担心自己的鞋子，觉得那不是对的款式，不是他在MTV上看到的那种。我分不清他是病了，还是只是想折磨我。我开车离开时想，我对这种疾病一无所知，我知道的比我开始时还要少。我花了两天时间到处开车，只挣了30美元。我感到非常、非常疲惫。
The house is dark as all the windows have heavy curtains pulled nearly shut. The curtains over the big picture window in the living room are open just a bit, and the light cuts through like a laser beam and hits the red, shag carpet, throwing up small dust particles and cigarette ash. Two feet away from the light, near the television, is a slice of pizza lying upside down in the carpet. I'm interviewing a woman, a mother, and her teenage daughter is on the phone talking to her boyfriend, or rather a series of boyfriends who call and call, and all of them wanted to go out right now, but her mother won't let her. She's trying to answer my questions, trying to concentrate and be polite, but she's mainly listening to what her daughter is saying on the phone. And will suddenly switch from saying, "No, no, I've been feeling fine. I haven't had a relapse and months," to screaming out, "Is that John? I told you never to talk to him again." Or, "Who is it? Is it a boy? You can't go out. Tell him he has to come over here."
房子很暗，所有的窗户都拉着厚重的窗帘。客厅大落地窗上的窗帘只拉开了一点，光线像激光束一样切进来，打在红色的长毛地毯上，激起微小的尘埃和烟灰。离光线两英尺远的地方，靠近电视机，有一片披萨倒扣在地毯上。我正在采访一位女士，一位母亲，她的十几岁女儿正在电话里和男朋友说话，或者说是一连串的男朋友打来电话，所有人都想现在就出去，但她母亲不让她出去。她试图回答我的问题，试图集中注意力并保持礼貌，但她主要是在听女儿在电话里说什么。然后会突然从说“不，不，我一直感觉很好。我几个月都没有复发了”转向尖叫：“那是约翰吗？我告诉你永远不要再和他说话了。”或者，“那是谁？是个男孩吗？你不能出去。告诉他，他必须过来这里。”
I can't stop looking at the slice of pizza on the carpet. I keep looking at the slice of pizza because it's the only clue that the woman is sick. I mean she has a teenage daughter and a dirty house, and maybe she shouldn't try to wear her makeup to bed, but these are not necessarily symptoms of schizophrenia. She seems to be fine, just worn out, until I get to the question, "Have you been worrying a lot?" And she says yes she has. She's been worrying a lot that the elders of the Church, the Mormon Church, will take her daughter away from her.
我无法停止盯着地毯上的那片披萨。我一直盯着那片披萨，因为它是那位女士生病的唯一线索。我是说她有一个十几岁的女儿和一间脏乱的房子，也许她不该试图带着妆睡觉，但这并不一定就是精神分裂症的症状。她看起来没问题，只是很疲惫，直到我问到这个问题：“你最近一直在担心吗？”她说是的，她一直在担心。她一直担心教会的长老，摩门教会，会把她的女儿从她身边带走。
And I ask her why, and she says because she stopped taking her medication. And I ask her, "Why did you stop taking your medication?" And she says that the only reason she takes it is because she told her bishop that she was visited by the archangel Gabriel, and that she had had sex with him. And then, she was also visited by the archangel Michael, and that she had sex with both of them at once. And that they'd ravished her almost every night. So her bishop made her go to a doctor, and the doctor gave her some pills. And she took the pills, and the angels stopped coming. The bishop and the elders had told her that if she had sex with any more angels, they'd take her daughter away. So I asked her again why she'd stopped taking her medication. And she says, "I'm lonely. I miss them. I want them to come back."
我问她为什么，她说因为她停止服药了。我问她：“你为什么停止服药？”她说她吃药的唯一原因是她告诉主教她被加百列大天使探访了，并且她和他发生了性关系。然后，她也被米迦勒大天使探访过，她同时和他们两个发生了性关系。而且他们几乎每晚都强暴她。所以她的主教让她去看医生，医生给了她一些药片。她吃了药，天使们就不再来了。主教和长老们告诉她，如果她再和任何天使发生性关系，他们就会把她的女儿带走。所以我再次问她为什么停止服药。她说：“我很孤独。我想念他们。我想要他们回来。”
Today in a restaurant eating lunch between interviews, I decided to take the test. I answered the questions and scored myself appropriately, and at some point I realized I wasn't doing so well. I decided not to even add up the points because then I'd be left with a score, and I'd never forget it. If I were to write a report on myself, it would sound something like this.
今天在采访之间的午餐时间在餐馆里，我决定自己做这个测试。我回答了问题并给自己打了分，在某个时刻，我意识到我做得不太好。我决定甚至不去加总分数，因为那样我就有了一个分数，我将永远无法忘记它。如果我要写一份关于我自己的报告，它听起来会是这样的。
"The patient is 36 years old and lives alone since his wife left him three weeks ago. She took the kids and all the silverware, except for a large knife and a bowl and a coffee cup. The patient admits that her leaving may have had something to do with the fact that without warning, he completely gutted the house, tore out all the walls and ceilings, all the lath and plaster right down to the studs. He says he did this in order to live like a primitive. When asked if he was successful, he says it was the first step in the right direction."
“患者36岁，自从三周前妻子离开他后就独自一人居住。她带走了孩子和所有的餐具，只留下了一把大刀、一个碗和一个咖啡杯。患者承认她的离开可能与他毫无预兆地彻底清空了房子，拆掉了所有的墙壁和天花板，所有的板条和石膏一直拆到立柱有关。他说他这样做是为了像原始人一样生活。当被问及他是否成功时，他说这是朝正确方向迈出的第一步。”
"The patient is a 36-year-old male who lives alone since his wife and children left him two months ago. He says there's a darkness that separates him from other people, a heavy darkness, like looking at a person from the bottom of a well. He believes that if he could say the right words, then the darkness would go away. He says he sometimes knows the right words but cannot say them. Other times, he can't even think of the words to say."
“患者是一名36岁的男性，自从两个月前妻子和孩子离开他后就独自居住。他说有一种黑暗将他与其他人隔开，一种沉重的黑暗，就像从井底看一个人一样。他相信如果能说出正确的话，那么黑暗就会消失。他说他有时知道正确的话，却说不出来。其他时候，他甚至连想说的话都想不出来。”
"The patient is 36 years old and lives alone since his wife and children left him three months ago. Last week, he went fishing in the [? San Juans and now believes that there's no better fisherman than himself. He says, 'I can't tell you about it because talking about fishing is silly, like farting and tap dancing at the same time. All I can say is I walk around in the water, and I know the instant that fish will jump for the fly. I cut open their stomachs and squeeze out the bugs in my hand, study what they eat, how it all gets digested, even the exoskeleton and wings.' He says he was sick before, but now he's OK, and that it was the fly rod, just holding the rod in his hand, that cured him. His house is clean. The electricity is on. The walls have been sheet-rocked and painted white. He says, 'I'll have to ask her, beg her, and maybe she'll come back.'"
“患者36岁，自从三个月前妻子和孩子离开他后就独自居住。上周，他去圣胡安钓鱼，现在相信没有比他更出色的渔夫了。他说：‘我不能告诉你关于它的事，因为谈论钓鱼很愚蠢，就像一边放屁一边跳踢踏舞。我只能说，我在水里走来走去，我知道鱼什么时候会去咬钩。我切开它们的胃，把虫子挤在手里，研究它们吃什么，这一切是如何被消化的，甚至是外骨骼和翅膀。’他说他以前病了，但现在他很好，是飞蝇钓竿，仅仅是握着那根杆子，就治好了他。他的房子很干净。电通了。墙壁重新铺了石膏板并漆成了白色。他说：‘我得去问她，求她，也许她会回来。’”
That's Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City. Years after writing that story, it is now in print in a collection of Scott's work, which comes out in March, called Running After Antelope. Coming up, more stories about jobs that take over your life.
那是盐湖城的斯科特·卡里尔。在写下那个故事多年后，它现在被收录在斯科特的文集里，该书将于三月出版，书名叫《追逐羚羊》。接下来，还有更多关于占据你生活的工作的故事。
Act Two, Tribe. Of course this is This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And a couple weeks ago, coming out of The Bluebird, a bar here on Clybourn Avenue in Chicago. I was with my friend Teresa, and we're going out of the bar. And we walk, and there's this group of maybe 40 people that comes skipping. I mean that's a word you don't really use very often to describe people, adults, in front of you, but they were more or less skipping down the street, chattering, half walking, half running. And they greet us joyously and look us in the eye. And they surround us, and they seem curious and happy and alive. It seems like a group of three or four dozen people who are in love, in love, all of them.
第二幕，部落。当然，这是《这个美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。几周前，我从芝加哥克莱伯恩大道上的一家酒吧“蓝鸟”出来。我和朋友特蕾莎在一起，我们走出酒吧。我们走着，遇到了一群大约40人，他们正在跳跃着走过来。我是说这是一个用来描述成年人时并不常用的词，但他们或多或少是在街上跳跃着走，喋喋不休，半走半跑。他们快乐地向我们打招呼，注视着我们的眼睛。他们围住我们，看起来既好奇又快乐，充满活力。这看起来像是一群三四十个坠入爱河的人，他们都坠入爱河了。
It turns out it's the cast of Hair, which is in town, or was in town then. These are mostly college kids from Cal State Fullerton who've been drafted into this road company of the show, grown long hair. One woman tells me, "I have never felt so strongly about love and peace and the war." They're not just in a play, they say, they are on a mission, a mission to spread tolerance and love. And they say things like--
事实证明，他们是音乐剧《毛发》的演员，当时正在城里演出。他们大多是来自加州州立大学富勒顿分校的大学生，被征召进这部戏的巡回演出剧团，留起了长发。一位女性告诉我：“我从未对爱、和平与战争有过如此强烈的感受。”他们说，他们不仅仅是在演戏，他们是在执行一项任务，一项传播宽容与爱的任务。他们会说这样的话——
1996, we need the message of love, peace and freedom because without a small group of people that can hold onto those old values, we're in major trouble. The idea is we have to live the life so that we can continue that that life is real.
1996年，我们需要爱、和平与自由的信息，因为如果没有一小群人能够坚守这些古老的价值观，我们将陷入大麻烦。这个想法是，我们必须活出这种生活，这样我们才能延续这种生活，这种生活是真实的。
They're all wearing matching necklaces with these little Native American stones hung on them, signifying that they're are members of a tribe they call the Potawatomi Tribe. They all live together in a dorm. And a couple days after this, Peter Clowney, from the staff of our radio show, decided to visit that dorm to see just how much this job, being in this play, had taken over their lives.
他们都戴着配套的项链，上面挂着这些小小的美洲原住民石头，象征着他们是一个他们称之为波塔瓦托米部落的成员。他们都住在一个宿舍里。几天后，我们节目的员工彼得·克劳尼决定去参观那个宿舍，看看这份工作，在这个剧团里演戏，到底在多大程度上占据了他们的生活。
When I arrive at the dorm, it's 1:30 in the afternoon, and most of the tribe is just getting out of bed. The show's choreographer is playing Prince on a boombox in the second floor lobby to wake everyone up. About six people dance, and late risers in towels and boxers weave their way around them on their way to the showers. Some of them stop for hugs. I collar one for questioning.
我到达宿舍时是下午1点半，部落的大多数成员才刚刚起床。这部戏的编舞正在二楼大厅用手提音响播放王子的音乐来叫醒大家。大约有六个人在跳舞，还有些穿着毛巾和拳击短裤的人在去洗澡的路上绕过他们。有些人停下来拥抱。我抓住一个人进行盘问。
So are you a happy member of the tribe?
那么，你是这个部落快乐的一员吗？
Oh, extremely happy, extremely happy. I've never been happier, ever.
噢，非常快乐，非常快乐。我从来没有这么快乐过，从来没有。
What does the tribe do for you?
部落为你做了什么？
They give me so much love, love that I've never felt before in my entire. It's so scary because I called my mom on Sunday, and I told her how this has been really life-changing and everything. And I really scared her. But I mean it's just been so great. I wish it could never end. I really do.
他们给了我太多的爱，我一生中从未感受过的爱。这太可怕了，因为我在周日给我妈妈打电话，我告诉她这件事是如何真正改变了我的生活等等。我真的吓坏她了。但我的意思是这真的很棒。我希望它永远不会结束。我真的这么想。
I hear this maybe a dozen times while I hang out with the tribe. Phyllis Ivy, an enthusiastic member of the tribe, listens in on my interview with Ephraim, and then she jumps in.
我和部落待在一起时，这种话我听到了不下十几次。部落的一位热心成员菲利斯·艾维在旁听了我对埃弗拉伊姆的采访，然后她插话了。
I have a question, Ephraim. Do you differentiate the show, Hair , from the tribe, or is this a production that-- because we're going to go on. We're all going to play other roles and everything. I mean true, this is such a life-changing experience for me as well, but when you get down to it, we are actors. We are paid to play this role.
埃弗拉伊姆，我有一个问题。你是把戏《毛发》和部落区分开来，还是这是一部……因为我们要继续演下去。我们都要扮演其他的角色等等。我的意思是，诚然，这对我也确实是一次改变人生的经历，但归根结底，我们是演员。我们拿钱扮演这个角色。
This show is so different thought.
但这出戏很不一样。
True.
真的。
I will never be as close to other actors as I will to this group.
我永远不会像在这个群体中那样与其他演员如此亲近。
The original producer or Hair, Michael Butler, traveled the country for two years looking for a college production of the show that he could turn into a national touring company. He chose this group because on stage, in some undefinable way, they seem like a real tribe. They have the spirit of a real tribe, even if they aren't the greatest singers and dancers. And in the early days of rehearsals for the national tour, they had encounter sessions where it was drilled into them that this is more than just a show, that this is more than just a business, that they really are a tribe.
《毛发》的原制片人迈克尔·巴特勒在全国游历了两年，寻找一个他可以将其改编成全国巡回演出的大学剧团。他选择了这个群体，因为在舞台上，以某种难以定义的方式，他们看起来像一个真正的部落。他们有真正部落的精神，即使他们不是最出色的歌手和舞者。在全国巡演排练初期，他们进行过交流会议，他们被反复灌输这不仅仅是一场表演，不仅仅是一门生意，他们真的是一个部落。
But of course it is a business. People have jobs to do. They have to be able to sing and act and show up on time. And when the producers take the show on the road, they'll face a business problem. There's only enough money to bring about 25 of the cast members, downsizing from 38. Phyllis Ivy says it'd be understandable if they chose the best singers and performers.
但当然，这确实是一门生意。人们有工作要做。他们必须能够唱歌、演戏，并且准时到场。当制片人带着演出上路时，他们将面临一个商业问题。只有足够的钱来带大约25名演员，从38人缩减。菲利斯·艾维说，如果他们选择最好的歌手和表演者，那是可以理解的。
There are people who can't sing in this show. There are people who can't hold pitch. There are people who can't act. There are people who can't dance. If we were to audition for this show, if in New York, Michael Butler wanted to hold auditions for the world tour of Hair, there are not a lot of people in this cast who would be in that show.
这个戏里有些人根本不会唱歌。有些人唱不准音。有些人不会演戏。有些人不会跳舞。如果我们为这部戏试镜，如果迈克尔·巴特勒想在纽约为《毛发》的世界巡演举行试镜，这个剧团里没有多少人能进入那场演出。
This sounds common sense, but within the world of this tribe, it's heresy. They've been told that everyone belongs in the tribe if they believe in it and work hard. A few cast members stand and listen to Phyllis say this with their arms crossed. And then they come over. "Can I pipe in?" one of them asks.
这听起来是常识，但在部落的世界里，这是异端。他们被告知，只要他们相信并努力工作，每个人都属于这个部落。几名演员停下来听菲利斯说这些，双臂交叉。然后他们走了过来。“我可以插一句吗？”其中一个人问。
Can we pipe in?
我们可以插一句吗？
Sure.
当然。
OK, because I don't want anything negative to be--
好的，因为我不希望有任何负面的东西被……
Oh no.
噢不。
But you know what? We've got more heart and soul than any of these casts put together, and our show is actually pretty incredible. And I know I never would have probably had a chance because I'm not a strong singer, but with my dedication and my heart and soul involved in the show, it's been life-changing. And it's a lot more than that.
但你知道吗？我们比这些剧团加起来都要有心和灵魂，我们的表演其实相当不可思议。我知道我可能永远没有机会，因为我不是个强有力的歌手，但随着我的投入，我的心和灵魂参与其中，它改变了人生。而且远不止于此。
Sasha is one of those people who cannot really-- she's not a vocal person. But she is a great and every bit a part of the show as you and I are.
萨莎是那些真正不能……她不是一个声音洪亮的人。但她很棒，而且和你我一样，是这部戏不可或缺的一部分。
When Phyllis Ivy responds, she's trembling.
当菲利斯·艾维回应时，她在发抖。
I didn't want to appear like that. However, I mean we've talked about tribe, and we've talked about how we all bring in individual talents into the show.
我不想表现得那样。然而，我的意思是，我们谈论过部落，我们也谈论过我们每个人是如何把个人才华带进这部戏的。
I walk downstairs, and I'm surprised to see how quickly word spreads that I saw them disagreeing. They want me to believe they get along. When I go into the rec room, where some of the guys are playing ping pong, a cast member comes looking for Nathan, one of the de facto leaders of the tribe.
我走下楼，我很惊讶地看到我看到他们发生分歧的消息传得有多快。他们想让我相信他们相处得很好。当我走进娱乐室，那里有些人在打乒乓球时，一名演员过来寻找内森，部落的实际领导人之一。
Hey, I have to talk to you right fast.
嘿，我得马上和你谈谈。
You have to talk to me?
你得和我谈谈？
Yeah, real quick.
是啊，很快。
There's a hurried conversation around the corner. Nathan returns with a speech to make to me.
转角处有一段匆忙的谈话。内森回来后准备对我发表讲话。
I know that everybody wants the best for this show. If it goes on with the 38 people we have now, great. But if not, those people are going to obviously go through a lot of pain and a lot of hurt. But then I think that their belief in the show is going to continue to just send us energy and vibes and say, we still love you guys really and we want you to do the best that you can.
我知道每个人都希望这场演出最好。如果能由我们现在的38个人继续演下去，那太棒了。但如果不能，那些人显然会经历很多痛苦和伤害。但我想他们对这部戏的信念会继续为我们注入能量和氛围，说，我们仍然爱你们，我们希望你们尽力做到最好。
Nathan is not just spinning me. He believes this. He's completely sincere. Of everyone in this group, Nathan, at 21, is the one everyone says is a real hippie. Nathan dressed like a hippie. He looked like a hippie even before he got a part in Hair. An for nine months now, he's been a peacekeeper in the group, someone whose earnestness and belief in getting along and taking care of each other has helped keep the group going.
内森不仅仅是在敷衍我。他是真的相信这一点。在这个群体中，21岁的内森是每个人都说是个真正的嬉皮士的人。内森的打扮就像个嬉皮士。甚至在他得到《毛发》里的角色之前，他看起来就像个嬉皮士。九个月来，他一直是群体里的和平使者，他的真诚以及对和睦相处、相互照顾的信念帮助维持了这个群体的运作。
But now, while Nathan talks about love holding the cast together even when 13 people might get cut, one of the guys in the room, Rod, snorts and mutters under his breath. And then he lays into Nathan.
但现在，当内森谈论爱把演员团结在一起，即使13个人可能会被裁掉时，房间里的一个人，罗德，哼了一声，低声咕哝着。然后他开始数落内森。
It's [BLEEP], Nate, to say that you're not going to have animosity, and that you'd be saying good vibes. Who's going to be sending good vibes, man?
这真是[哔——]，内特，说你不会有敌意，说你会发出好的共鸣。谁会发出好的共鸣，伙计？
OK, then maybe not for you. But wouldn't you be happy if I went on tour?
好吧，那也许对你不适用。但如果你去巡演，你会高兴吗？
Who do you know that's going to be sending good vibes when they don't get to go?
谁会知道在他们没能去巡演时会发出好的共鸣？
Are you going to go on the tour?
你要去巡演吗？
Probably not. I would love to, but I doubt it. I'll have to get down on my hands and [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
可能不会。我很想去，但我怀疑能行。我得跪着[语音不清]。
Let me go. What about ping pong man?
让我走吧。乒乓球那个呢？
No, I really want to go. And if I don't go, I'm going to be really miserable and really hateful.
不，我真的很想去。如果我不去，我会非常痛苦，非常可恨。
And he's honest about it too.
他对此也很诚实。
I'm going to be-- I don't know. Nathan, you know you're going to go.
我会——我不知道。内森，你知道你会去的。
I don't know that I'm going to go.
我不知道我会去。
The only guy with real long hair and a beard, and they're going to leave him here. Give me a break.
唯一留着真正长发和胡子的家伙，他们要让他留在这里。饶了我吧。
Unintentionally over the course of nine months, the tribe has revived another part of '60's communal living along with peace and love. It's resentment, competitiveness and paranoia. I was taken aback when I asked Derek an innocent question like, "What's the tribe like?" And he responded this way.
在九个月的过程中，这个部落在无意中重现了60年代公社生活的另一部分，伴随着和平与爱。那就是怨恨、竞争和偏执。当我问德里克一个无辜的问题，比如“部落是什么样的？”而他这样回应时，我感到震惊。
Here's the point. I'm going to tell you this. Whoever doesn't want to be Potawatomi shouldn't be Potawatomi, and they really shouldn't be in the Potawatomi tribe, which will happen. If you cannot be Potawatomi, walk. If you don't want to be a tribe, get out. If you don't like what we do, get out. It's where we are. And if you think that you can stay in and still want to put a monkey wrench in our action, you will not. We will put you out. We invite you in, and we ask you to leave.
重点是这个。我要告诉你这一点。谁不想成为波塔瓦托米人就不应该成为波塔瓦托米人，他们真的不应该待在波塔瓦托米部落里，这将会发生。如果你不能成为波塔瓦托米人，走人。如果你不想成为一个部落，滚蛋。如果你不喜欢我们做的事情，滚蛋。这就是我们所在的地方。如果你认为你可以留下来，但仍然想在我们的行动中制造麻烦，你不能。我们会把你踢出去。我们邀请你进来，我们也要求你离开。
I did those interviews a few weeks ago. And for now, the cast is off-tour. Most of them are at school. No decisions have been made yet about who would tour in the spring, and so everyone is still getting along. When they run into each other at school though, members of the tribe still hug each other, just like they always have. And another student said to them recently, "When are you guys going to cut out all that love crap?"
我几周前做了那些采访。目前，剧团不在巡演。他们大多数人在上学。关于谁将在春天巡演还没有做出决定，所以大家目前还相处得很好。不过，当他们在学校遇到彼此时，部落成员仍然像往常一样拥抱对方。另一名学生最近对他们说：“你们什么时候才能停止那些爱的废话？”
Well, coming up, guys who get thrown in jail because they refuse to work in conditions that get 320 of their coworkers blown up. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
好吧，接下来，那些仅仅因为拒绝在导致320名同事被炸飞的环境下工作就被关进监狱的人们的故事。那将在来自国际公共广播电台的节目继续后的一分钟里播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week of course we bring you a variety of stories around some theme. Today's theme, the job that takes over your life.
这里是《这个美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们当然会围绕某个主题为您带来各种各样的故事。今天的主题，占据你生活的工作。
We interrupt this broadcast to bring you this important bulletin from the United Press. Flash, Washington. The White House announces Japanese attack on Pearl Harbor. Stay tuned to WOR for further development, which will be broadcast immediately as received.
我们要中断这次广播，为您带来这条来自合众国际社的重要公报。快讯，华盛顿。白宫宣布日本袭击珍珠港。请继续锁定WOR以获取进一步的发展，我们将在收到消息后立即进行广播。
After Pearl Harbor, the Navy opened to blacks for the first time. But rather than get sent out on ships, one large group of African American men found themselves stationed in one of the least desirable dumps. It was literally a dump, an ammo dump called Port Chicago. This is just north of San Francisco. Now, the place is called Concord Naval Weapons Station. Their job was to load ammunition onto ships, and conditions were so unsafe that it was the site of the worst stateside disaster of the war. On July 17, 1944, two ships blew up, killing 320 men and rocking all of San Francisco in what many people thought was just an earthquake.
珍珠港事件后，海军首次向黑人开放。但他们并没有被派往船上，一大群非裔美国男性发现自己驻扎在最不受欢迎的垃圾场之一。那真的是一个垃圾场，一个叫芝加哥港的弹药库。这就在旧金山以北。现在，那个地方叫康科德海军武器站。他们的工作是向船上装载弹药，环境非常不安全，以至于它成为了战争中本土最严重的灾难发生地。1944年7月17日，两艘船发生爆炸，造成320人死亡，整个旧金山都在震动，许多人以为那只是一场地震。
A court of inquiry blamed the sailors. It concluded-- here's a quote, "The colored enlisted personnel are neither temperamentally nor intellectually capable of handling high explosives." Well, when survivors were ordered right back to work-- the guys who had survived the whole thing, they were sent right back to work. They were told, go back to work under the same conditions. 50 of them refused, and they were sentenced to up to 15 years of hard labor.
调查法庭指责了水手。报告得出的结论是——这里引用一下：“黑人入伍人员在性情和智力上都不具备处理高爆炸药的能力。”好吧，当幸存者被命令立即回到工作岗位时——那些在整个事件中幸存下来的家伙们，他们被直接送回去工作。他们被告知，回到同样的环境中去工作。其中50人拒绝了，他们被判处最高15年的苦役。
Over the years since then, there have been many attempts to clear their names, including in 1944 by then civil rights attorney, Thurgood Marshall. Dan Collison spoke with five survivors of the incident about what really happened at Port Chicago.
从那以后的多年里，有许多尝试为他们洗清名声，包括1944年时任民权律师瑟古德·马歇尔的努力。丹·科利森与该事件的五名幸存者谈论了在芝加哥港到底发生了什么。
We sent everything out of there, from 30-30 rifle cartridges all the way up to 2,000 pound blockbusters, we called them.
我们从那里运出一切东西，从30-30步枪弹药一直到我们称之为2000磅重磅炸弹的东西。
My job basically was to load ammunition with the crew, which worked in the hold of the ship.
我的工作基本上是和在船舱里工作的船员一起装载弹药。
You'd be down in the hold. Here come those big bombs and things coming down the ramp-way they had built. But sometimes, they let it come down too fast. And they hit together, and they made a loud noise.
你会待在货舱里。那些大炸弹之类的东西顺着他们建造的坡道下来了。但有时，他们让它下来得太快了。它们撞在一起，发出巨大的声响。
You hear this all night long, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
你整晚都能听到这个，砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰。
And this would almost give you a heart attack. Yeah, you would almost have a heart attack. And so we used to ask them sometimes, say, "Is there any danger of this ammunition exploding?" They'd say, "Oh no, don't worry about it. It's safe. It's not live." They said they don't have any detonators in them.
这几乎会让你心脏病发作。是的，你几乎会心脏病发作。所以我们有时会问他们，说：“这些弹药有爆炸的危险吗？”他们会说：“噢不，别担心。这是安全的。它没有引信。”他们说里面没有任何雷管。
We were not trained to load ammunition. We would take ammunition-- we'd take a crowbar when we had to go so high. We'd take that crowbar and push that ammunition up there because they told us it would not explode because it didn't have any detonator in it. We believed that.
我们没有受过装载弹药的训练。我们会在必须装得那么高时使用撬棍。我们会拿那根撬棍把弹药推上去，因为他们告诉我们它不会爆炸，因为它没有任何雷管。我们相信了这一点。
All of the loading crews were black. There were no white loading crews. You didn't have a lot of white people that you saw.
所有的装载船员都是黑人。没有白人装载船员。你没见到多少白人。
We only had basically one officer, and he would be the only person white.
我们基本上只有一个军官，而且他会是唯一的白人。
Well, the white officers, they didn't have much to do with us anymore. And to stand around and supervise and see that we loaded that ammunition.
好吧，白人军官们，他们不再怎么和我们打交道了。只是站在旁边监督，确保我们装载了那些弹药。
It was pressure. We were told that so much had to be done that night. We had to do this so much. It was a rush race.
那是压力。我们被告知那晚必须完成很多工作。我们必须做这么多。这是一场赛跑。
And the division commanders push the petty officers to push the man to load as much as they could as fast as they could. But we knew they were betting, $100 or so that my division will put on more ammunition than your division.
师指挥官催促士官们催促人们尽快装载尽可能多的弹药。但我们知道他们在打赌，大约100美元，赌我的部队装载的弹药比你的部队多。
Each one would put up money that their division would out-load the other one for those particular shifts or that particular day. They had day lotteries, week, and whole ship lottery.
每个人都会出钱赌他们的部队在那特定的轮班或那一天装载得比对方多。他们有日赌、周赌和整船的赌注。
Frequently, the urgent need for ammunition forced the depot to load two ships at the same time at the same pier. So it was on the night of July 17, 1944. The Quinault Victory and the E.A. Bryan were moored at the Naval magazine, Port Chicago. 16 cars of ammunition and bombs were spotted on the pier beside the Quinault Victory as the ship rigged to load. Bryan had been loading day and night for more than three days. 3.5 million pounds of explosives were aboard or waiting nearby on the pier. Everything was normal until 10:19.
由于对弹药的迫切需求，该仓库经常被迫同时在同一个码头装载两艘船。所以1944年7月17日的那晚也是如此。基诺尔特胜利号和E.A.布莱恩号停泊在海军杂志社芝加哥港。基诺尔特胜利号旁边码头上停着16车弹药和炸弹，该船正准备进行装载。布莱恩号已经昼夜不停地装载了三天多。350万磅炸药已经在船上或在附近的码头上等待。直到10点19分一切都很正常。
It was a Monday, a hot July day. And for some reason, the day was kind of a day that I felt a great foreboding, and I don't know why.
那是一个周一，炎热的七月天。出于某种原因，那一天我感到一种巨大的预感，我不知道为什么。
The lights were out at 10:00. So the lights went out at 10:00. We were all returned to our bunk.
10点钟熄灯了。所以10点钟灯灭了。我们都回到铺位上。
I had pimples, still being a teenager. So nightly, I would go in and tidy myself up and put on Noxzema. And I got back to my locker, put my gear away, said my prayers and leaped up-- I had a top rack-- and I leaped up in the rack. And here comes the voice over the intercom system again. "Lights out. Quiet about the deck."
我当时还是个青少年，脸上长着痘痘。所以每晚我都会进去整理一下自己，涂上Noxzema。我回到储物柜，把东西放好，做了祷告，跳了上去——我睡的是上铺——我跳进铺位。对讲系统里又传来了声音。“熄灯。甲板上保持安静。”
I'm laying there with my hands behind my head looking out at the sky. And at that time, I guess a few minutes after the lights went out, the sky lit up, and it was just like the sun rose. Everything was bright. You could see all the buildings for a second.
我躺在那里，双手放在脑后看着天空。就在那时，我想是在灯熄灭几分钟后，天空亮了起来，就像太阳升起一样。一切都变得明亮。你可以看到所有的建筑一秒钟。
Shortly after that, here comes the second explosion, filling the sky with all kinds of lights and colors like at a fourth of July celebration.
紧接着，第二次爆炸来了，天空中充满了各种光和颜色，就像国庆节庆典一样。
Then came the concussion. The concussion blew a hole in my body. My left arm got mutilated. Face, head, neck, shoulders and body got mutilated. That was the first explosion. The second was just a few seconds afterwards. That lifted me out of the bunk and threw me on the floor.
然后是冲击波。冲击波在我的身体上炸开了一个洞。我的左臂被炸残了。脸、头、脖子、肩膀和身体都被炸残了。那是第一次爆炸。第二次只是在几秒钟之后。它把我从铺位上掀了起来，扔在了地板上。
All hell broke loose, and it was just a lot of confusion because glass was everywhere. Men were just in fear, and some had run out in their bare feet and shorts. And it was just bedlam.
所有的一切都乱套了，到处都是混乱，因为到处都是玻璃。人们陷入了恐惧，有些人光着脚穿着短裤跑了出去。简直是一片混乱。
You could hear the people now screaming and yelling, "Get out of the barracks. It's coming down." So I myself scuffled, crawled out and took off for the outside.
你现在可以听到人们在尖叫和吼叫，“离开营房。它要塌了。”所以我自己挣扎着，爬了出去，向外面跑去。
And when there were no other explosions, then I crawled out. But then I noticed that I couldn't see clearly. And that's when I first realized then that I was hurt. And I called to my buddy, "Hey Morris, come and get me and take me to the sick bay." And then somebody else hollered, "Well, the sick bay has been blown up."
当没有其他爆炸发生时，我爬了出来。但我注意到我看不清楚。那就是我第一次意识到我受伤了的时候。我喊我的伙伴，“嘿，莫里斯，过来接我，把我带到医务室。”然后有人喊，“好吧，医务室已经被炸毁了。”
When I got outside, there were a few people outside yelling for volunteers to go down to the docks. I went up to the guy and said, "Hey, I want to volunteer." He asked me, "Did you see Percy get out of the barracks?" He didn't recognize me. He was my squad leader because my face was so mutilated from the blood and guts.
当我走到外面时，有几个人在外面喊着志愿者去码头。我走到那个人跟前说，“嘿，我想自愿参加。”他问我，“你看到珀西从营房里出来了吗？”他没认出我。他是我的班长，因为我的脸被血和内脏弄得面目全非。
The left eye was lacerated so badly that that was removed that night. And then the right was lacerated, and so consequently, the right eye-- eventually, I lost the sight in that too. So that was the beginning of the end and caused me to be a blind person.
左眼撕裂得太严重，那天晚上被摘除了。然后右眼也被撕裂了，结果，右眼——最终，我也失去了那里的视力。所以那是终结的开始，导致我成了一个盲人。
In the Pacific war, American battleships, cruisers and destroyers shelled Guam island on Sunday for the second straight day. Here at home, officials say that 337 persons are known dead or missing and presumed dead, more than 300 hundred others injured, as the result of last night's explosion of two ammunition ships at Port Chicago in upper San Francisco Bay. And now, General Electric takes you to Washington.
在太平洋战争中，美国战列舰、巡洋舰和驱逐舰周日连续第二天炮击关岛。在国内，官员们表示，已有337人确认死亡或失踪并推定死亡，另有300多人受伤，这是昨晚在旧金山上湾芝加哥港两艘弹药船爆炸的结果。现在，通用电气带您去往华盛顿。
The first thing I thought, same thing, Pearl Harbor again So that's what it was like, just like somebody dropped bombs over the whole thing. It didn't look like it was an explosion from one of the ships. It looked like a plane had come down and just bombarded the place.
我想到的第一件事，同样的事情，珍珠港再次发生了。所以就是那样，就像有人把炸弹扔在整个地方一样。看起来不像是一艘船的爆炸。看起来像是一架飞机下来轰炸了这个地方。
In the waterfront barracks and administration area, buildings crumpled like cardboard, roofs blown off, walls gone. In the vicinity of the loading piers, total destruction. Both ships broken, twisted hulks.
在海滨营房和行政区，建筑像硬纸板一样倒塌，屋顶被掀翻，墙壁消失了。在装载码头附近，彻底被毁。两艘船变成了扭曲的废铁。
That was a shocking thing to see those ships torn up and seeing-- I was standing watch over all those dead bodies. I had to stand watch over that. That was my duty, and you couldn't tell one from the others.
看到那些船被撕成碎片，看到——我站在所有那些尸体上守卫，这是一件令人震惊的事情。我必须守卫那个。那是我的职责，你根本分不清谁是谁。
Meantime, the court of inquiry was collecting testimony and exhibits. Experts in all fields were called in to study the area. The cause of the explosion could not be fixed with certainty, but it was suspected that a depth charge was accidentally detonated.
与此同时，调查法庭正在收集证词和证据。各领域的专家都被召集来研究该区域。爆炸原因无法确定，但怀疑是一枚深水炸弹意外引爆了。
I knew what it was because we were expecting it all the time. We worked with that in mind that one day, that stuff would blow up.
我知道那是什么，因为我们一直都在预料着。我们怀着这样的念头工作，有一天，那些东西会爆炸。
We felt like just we were getting a raw deal because we were the ones that were doing the dirty work. We were the ones that were fooling with the ammunition. So why shouldn't we have a leave of absence to get away to get your nerves settled. But that didn't happen.
我们觉得我们受到了不公平对待，因为我们是那些做苦力活的人。我们是那些处理弹药的人。所以我们为什么不应该休假去缓解一下紧张的情绪。但那没有发生。
I think I was in the hospital maybe all week, and I think the day after, I returned to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. We were ordered to go to work, and I still was bandaged up, face, arms. My stitches were still there and everything. So we were lined up outside the barracks to go to work. They hadn't told us what we had to do yet, but then they said, "Forward march."
我想我在医院待了大概一周，我想在第二天，我就回到了[语音不清]。我们被命令去工作，我身上还绑着绷带，脸、胳膊。我的缝线还在，所有东西都在。所以我们在营房外排队去工作。他们还没有告诉我们要去做什么，但随后他们说，“齐步走。”
I was marching on the outside. I called cadence. Something like this, Hoo left, hoo left, hoo left right left. Left 2, 3, 4, left, right, left. And I believe it was Lieutenant Delucchi He said, "Column left." And when he said, "column left," everybody stopped because "column left" meant we were going to the docks. And the docks meant loading ammunition.
我在外面走着。我打着拍子。类似于这样，呼左，呼左，呼左右左。左2，3，4，左，右，左。我相信是德卢奇中尉。他说，“左转弯。”当他说“左转弯”时，每个人都停了下来，因为“左转弯”意味着我们要去码头。而码头意味着装载弹药。
They gave us an ultimatum, would you load ammunition? That's the ultimatum we had. And I told them myself, I said, "I am absolutely afraid," which I was. "I'm afraid to load ammunition." "You step over there then." Then they called another one, and I think he told them the same thing. "You step over there." And when the end of the day was over, I think just about all of us had stepped over there.
他们给了我们最后通牒，你会装载弹药吗？这就是我们得到的最后通牒。我自己告诉他们，我说，“我绝对很害怕，”我确实很害怕。“我很害怕装载弹药。”“那你站到那边去。”然后他们叫了另一个，我想他也告诉他们同样的事情。“你站到那边去。”当这一天结束时，我想我们几乎所有人都站到那边去了。
Then the Admiral came down and explained to us what our responsibilities were.
然后海军上将走过来向我们解释了我们的职责。
He told us-- he said "Well, one thing I want to tell you is that you could be charged with mutiny if you don't go back to work."
他告诉我们——他说“好吧，我想告诉你们的一件事是，如果你们不回去工作，你们可能会被指控哗变。”
And he explained at that time, if we refused to go back to work, he could have us shot.
而且他在那时解释说，如果我们拒绝回去工作，他可以把我们枪毙。
It was the cue. When he said you could be shot, then the fellows went to mumbling. You know, a lot of people are afraid to die.
那是个暗示。当他说你们可能会被枪毙时，伙计们开始嘟囔了。你知道，很多人害怕死亡。
From my upbringing, my mother taught me that if a white man threatened to hang you, he would do it at his first legal chance. And she told me about the Klan, and she was brought up in Mississippi. So I believed that they had a legal chance to shoot us, so I was afraid. So I said well, I'm not going to give them a change to shoot me. I'll go back to work.
从我的成长经历来看，我母亲教导我，如果一个白人威胁要绞死你，他会在第一个合法的机会这么做。她告诉我关于三K党的事，她是在密西西比州长大的。所以我相信他们有合法的机会枪毙我们，所以我很害怕。所以我说，好吧，我不会给他们机会枪毙我。我会回去工作的。
But then 50 of us decided we weren't going to go back to work. If we were going to get shot, they just had to shoot us because we weren't going to go back and load anymore ammunition.
但后来我们50个人决定我们不回去工作。如果我们要被枪毙，他们就得枪毙我们，因为我们不会再回去装载任何弹药了。
That's when we were arrested. I would say "arrested" because we were all shipped to I think it was Treasure Island. We were sent to stockade. Then we found out that we were charged with mutiny.
那就是我们被逮捕的时候。我会说“逮捕”，因为我们都被送到了我想是金银岛的地方。我们被送进了栅栏。然后我们发现我们被指控哗变。
We didn't commit any mutiny. We didn't take over any ship. We didn't take over a base. We had no weapons. We didn't even have a pen. We only refused to go back to work. Now how could that be mutiny?
我们没有进行任何哗变。我们没有接管任何船只。我们没有接管基地。我们没有武器。我们甚至连一支笔都没有。我们只是拒绝回去工作。那怎么能叫哗变呢？
I didn't know anything about mutiny. I just knew that I didn't want to work under the same conditions that I did work under and advance the chance of the same thing happening again.
我对哗变一无所知。我只知道我不想在同样的工作条件下工作，并增加同样的事情再次发生的可能性。
Well, the mutiny trial-- it's just like a thing that is cut and dry. We were all sitting over here. All the white officers were over here. We weren't allowed to say anything but what they would ask us.
好吧，哗变审判——就像一件枯燥无味的事情。我们都坐在这一边。所有的白人军官都在那边。我们除了他们问我们的话之外，不被允许说任何话。
The verdict was guilty as charged. I expected it from the way that the trial went. Of course, the length of the sentence was a surprise.
判决是有罪。我从审判的进程中就预料到了。当然，刑期的长短是个意外。
The lowest sentence in there, I think, was eight years. I had 12 years. And some had 16.
那里的最低刑期，我想是八年。我有12年。有些人有16年。
Well, I don't even remember crying behind it. I know I did after I got into prison, but it just seemed like it was something that was going to happen in the end after the trial. You know after you sit in the trial for a few days, then you see what was going down.
好吧，我甚至不记得为此哭过。我知道我进了监狱后哭过，但这似乎是审判结束后迟早会发生的事情。你知道，在你坐在法庭上几天后，你就明白发生了什么。
7:00 PM, Eastern Wartime. Bob Trout reporting. The Japanese have accepted our terms fully. That's the word we have just received from the White House in Washington. This, ladies and gentleman, is the end of the Second World War. The United Nations, on land, on the sea, in the air and to the four corners of the Earth, are united and are victorious.
东部战时时间晚上7点。鲍勃·特劳特报道。日本人已经完全接受了我们的条款。这是我们刚刚从华盛顿白宫收到的消息。各位女士先生，这是第二次世界大战的终结。联合国，在陆地上，在海洋上，在空中，在地球的四个角落，是团结的，是胜利的。
Well, when the war ended, after they had suspended our sentence, they had to release us. We got our discharge.
好吧，战争结束后，在他们中止了我们的刑期后，他们不得不释放我们。我们得到了退伍令。
My discharge from the Navy prevented me from receiving jobs that I would have received as a civilian. It branded me as a person incapable of following orders.
我在海军的退伍经历阻止了我获得本来可以作为平民获得的工作。它给我打上了无法服从命令的人的烙印。
I used to not be able to talk about it because it would hurt. It would hurt inside. You didn't want your friends to know that you was in the service, and you had been charged with mutiny. You didn't want people to think that you didn't like your country or something, that you'd do something like that. They're still in this country we knew about.
我过去无法谈论这件事，因为它会痛。它从内心深处痛。你不想让朋友知道你在服役，而且被指控哗变。你不想让人们认为你不喜欢你的国家或什么的，以至于你做出那样的事情。在这个我们所知的国家里，他们仍然存在。
Not even with the fellows I worked with. I didn't talk about it with my wife or children. Every time I would bring it up or even think about it, it looked like I got a hateful feeling in me. And it would just about tear me apart. I just hated the other race. And the hate was building up. It stayed with me. The hate stayed with me. Hate can really destroy a person. I could've been a better father, I believe, if I hadn't had that hate. I wouldn't abuse them or anything, but there were just things that I didn't talk about, things I held in, things I think I could have done better.
甚至和我一起工作的伙伴也不行。我没有和我的妻子或孩子谈论过它。每次我提起它甚至只是想到它，就好像我心里有一种仇恨的感觉。这几乎要把我撕碎了。我只是讨厌另一个种族。仇恨在积聚。它留在我身上。仇恨留在我身上。仇恨真的会摧毁一个人。我相信，如果我没有那种仇恨，我本可以成为一个更好的父亲。我不会虐待他们或什么的，但有些事情我没有说，有些事情我藏在心里，有些事情我觉得我本可以做得更好。
We can think of ourselves as a hero because we stood up for our rights. We stood up because we knew that we did not commit mutiny.
我们可以认为自己是英雄，因为我们为我们的权利挺身而出。我们挺身而出是因为我们知道我们没有进行哗变。
I think it was right. I don't know how heroic it is, but it was right.
我认为那是对的。我不知道这有多英勇，但这是对的。
I was fighting for something, and if you were to ask me to put a name on it, I don't know. But things were not right, and it was my desire to make things right. I have never felt ashamed of the decisions that I made. I did what I thought was best, and I did it in the best way I knew how.
我在为某件事而战，如果你要我给它起个名字，我不知道。但事情是不对的，我的愿望是让事情变得正确。我从未对自己做出的决定感到羞耻。我做了我认为最好的事情，而且我以我所知道的最好的方式做了。
Long ways back. It doesn't seem like it's been 50 years, and it still hangs over us at 50 years.
很久以前了。看起来好像并没有过50年，而且在50年后的今天，它仍然笼罩着我们。
Albert Williams, Freddie Meeks, Joseph Small, Percy Robinson and Robert Routh talked to Dan Collison, who produced that story. Gary Covina was the editor. Funding for the story came from the Funding Exchange. The Navy has made it a policy never to discuss the Port Chicago case, and has never exonerated the sailors who were court-martialed. In 1999, President Clinton pardoned one of the survivors, Freddie Meeks.
阿尔伯特·威廉姆斯、弗雷迪·米克斯、约瑟夫·斯莫尔、珀西·罗宾逊和罗伯特·鲁思与丹·科利森进行了交谈，丹·科利森制作了那个故事。加里·科维纳是编辑。故事的资金来自资金交流组织。海军有一项政策，从不讨论芝加哥港案件，也从未平反过那些被军事法庭审判的水手。1999年，克林顿总统赦免了幸存者之一弗雷迪·米克斯。
Act Four, Orientation. Our theme today is the job that takes over your life. And of course nearly any job can do that. You don't have to be working in unsafe conditions with millions of tons of explosives to have a job dominate you. In fact, I would argue even the most innocent, innocuous office job could do the trick. I offer as evidence this story by Daniel Orozco called "Orientation."
第四幕，入职指导。我们今天的主题是占据你生活的工作。当然，几乎任何工作都能做到这一点。你不必在充满数百万吨炸药的不安全条件下工作才能让工作统治你。事实上，我会说即使是最天真、最无害的办公室工作也能做到这一点。我提供这个由丹尼尔·奥罗斯科写的叫《入职指导》的故事作为证据。
Those are the offices, and these are the cubicles. That's my cubicle there, and this is your cubicle. This is your phone. Never answer your phone. Let the voicemail system answer it. This is your voicemail system manual. There are no personal phone calls allowed. These are your in and out boxes. You must pace your work. What do I mean? I'm glad you asked that. We pace our work according to eight-hour workday. If you have twelve hours of work in your inbox, for example, you must compress that work into an eight-hour day. If you have one hour of work in your inbox, you must expand that to fill the eight-hour day. That was a good question. Feel free to ask questions. Ask too many questions, however, and you may be let go.
那是办公室，这些是隔间。那是我的隔间，这是你的隔间。这是你的电话。永远不要接你的电话。让语音信箱系统接听。这是你的语音信箱系统手册。不允许进行私人电话。这些是你的收件箱和发件箱。你必须调节你的工作节奏。我是什么意思？我很高兴你问了这个问题。我们根据八小时工作日调节我们的工作节奏。例如，如果你的收件箱里有十二小时的工作量，你必须将这些工作压缩到八小时工作日内。如果你的收件箱里有一小时的工作量，你必须将其扩展到填满八小时工作日。这是一个好问题。随时欢迎提问。不过，问太多问题，你可能会被解雇。
Russell Nash, who sits in the cubicle to your left, is in love with Amanda Pierce, who sits in the cubicle to your right. They ride the same bus together after work. For Amanda Pierce, it's just a tedious bus ride made less tedious by the idle nattering of Russell Nash. But for Russell Nash, it's the highlight of his day, It's the highlight of his life. Russell Nash has put on 40 pounds and grows fatter with each passing month, nibbling on chips and cookies while peeking glumly over the partition at Amanda Pierce, engorging himself at home on cold pizza and ice cream while watching adult videos on TV.
坐在你左边隔间的拉塞尔·纳什爱上了坐在你右边隔间的阿曼达·皮尔斯。他们下班后一起坐同一辆公交车。对阿曼达·皮尔斯来说，这只是一次乏味的公交车旅程，因为拉塞尔·纳什的闲聊而变得不那么乏味。但对拉塞尔·纳什来说，这是他一天中最美好的时刻，这是他生命中最美好的时刻。拉塞尔·纳什体重增加了40磅，并且每个月都在变胖，一边啃着薯片和饼干，一边阴郁地看着隔板对面的阿曼达·皮尔斯，在家里一边看着电视上的成人录像带，一边吃着冷披萨和冰淇淋充饥。
Amanda Pierce, in the cubicle to your right, has a six-year-old son named Jamie who's autistic. Her cubicle is plastered from top to bottom with the boy's crayon artwork, sheet after sheet of precisely drawn concentric circles and ellipsis in black and yellow. She rotates them every other Friday. Be sure to comment on them. Amanda Pierce also has a husband who's a lawyer. He subjects her to an escalating array of painful and humiliating sex games to which Amanda Pierce reluctantly submits. But we're not supposed to know any of this. Do not let on. If you let on, you may be let go.
坐在你右边隔间的阿曼达·皮尔斯有一个六岁的儿子叫杰米，患有自闭症。她的隔间从上到下贴满了男孩的蜡笔画，一张又一张精确绘制的黑色和黄色同心圆和椭圆。她每隔一个周五就会轮换它们。一定要评论它们。阿曼达·皮尔斯还有个丈夫是律师。他让她进行一系列升级的、痛苦和羞辱性的性游戏，阿曼达·皮尔斯不情愿地顺从了。但我们不应该知道这一切。不要表露出来。如果你表露出来，你可能会被解雇。
Amanda Pierce, who tolerates Russell Nash, is in love with Albert Bosch, whose office is over there. Albert Bosch, who only dimly registers Amanda Pierce's existence, has eyes for Ellie Tapper, who sits over there. Ellie Tapper, who hates Albert Bosch, would walk through fire for Curtis Lance, but Curtis Lance hates Ellie Tapper. It's the world a funny place? Not in the ha-ha sense of course.
容忍拉塞尔·纳什的阿曼达·皮尔斯爱上了阿尔伯特·博世，他的办公室在那边。阿尔伯特·博世，对阿曼达·皮尔斯的存在只有模糊的印象，他眼里的目标是坐在那边的艾莉·塔珀。艾莉·塔珀，讨厌阿尔伯特·博世，愿意为柯蒂斯·兰斯赴汤蹈火，但柯蒂斯·兰斯讨厌艾莉·塔珀。这个世界是个有趣的地方吗？当然不是那种哈哈哈的意义上。
Anika Bloom in that cubicle. Last year, while reviewing quarterly reports in a meeting with Barry Hacker, Anika Bloom's left palm began to bleed. She fell into a trance, stared into her hand, told Barry Hacker when and how his wife would die. We laughed it off. She was, after all, a new employee. But Barry Hacker's wife is dead. So unless you want to know exactly when and how you'll die, never talk to Anika Bloom.
那个隔间里的阿尼卡·布鲁姆。去年，在与巴里·哈克的一次会议上审阅季度报告时，阿尼卡·布鲁姆的左手掌开始流血。她进入了恍惚状态，盯着她的手，告诉巴里·哈克他的妻子会在什么时候以什么方式死去。我们一笑置之。她毕竟是个新员工。但巴里·哈克的妻子死了。所以除非你想确切知道你什么时候会死，怎么死，永远不要和阿尼卡·布鲁姆说话。
For your information, we have a comprehensive health plan. Any catastrophic illness, any unforeseen tragedy is completely covered. All dependents are completely covered. This is our kitchenette, and this, this is our Mr. Coffee. This is the microwave oven. You are allowed to heat food in the microwave oven. You are not, however, allowed to cook food in the microwave oven. This is the refrigerator. You may put you lunch in it. Barry Hacker, who sits over there, steals food from the refrigerator. His petty theft is an outlet for his grief. Last New Year's Eve while kissing his wife, a blood vessel burst in her brain. Barry Hacker's wife was two months pregnant at the time and lingered in a coma for a half year before dying. It was a tragic loss for Barry Hacker. He hasn't been himself since. Barry Hacker's wife was a beautiful woman. She was also completely covered. Barry Hacker did not have to pay one dime.
顺便告诉你，我们有全面的健康保险。任何灾难性的疾病、任何不可预见的悲剧都完全覆盖。所有家属都完全覆盖。这是我们的厨房角落，这个，这是我们的咖啡机。这是微波炉。你可以在微波炉里加热食物。然而，你不可以在微波炉里烹饪食物。这是冰箱。你可以把你的午餐放在里面。坐在那边的巴里·哈克会从冰箱里偷食物。他的小偷小摸是他悲伤的一种宣泄。去年除夕夜在亲吻妻子时，她脑部血管爆裂。巴里·哈克的妻子当时怀孕两个月，在昏迷中徘徊了半年才去世。这对巴里·哈克来说是一个悲剧性的损失。他自那以后就不再是原来的自己了。巴里·哈克的妻子的确是一位美丽的女性。她也完全在保险范围内。巴里·哈克不需要支付一分钱。
But his dead wife haunts him. She haunts all of us. We have seen her reflected in the monitors of our computer moving past our cubicles. We've seen the dim shadow of her face in our photocopies. She pencils herself into the receptionist's appointment book with the notation, "To see Barry Hacker." She left messages in the receptionist's voicemail box, messages garbled by the electronic chirps and buzzes in the phone line, her voice echoing from an immense distance within the ambient hum. But the voice is hers, and beneath her voice, beneath the tidal whoosh of static and hiss, the gurgling and crying of a baby can be heard. In any case, if you bring a lunch, put a little something extra in it for Barry Hacker. We have four Barry's in the office. Isn't that a coincidence?
但他的亡妻一直困扰着他。她困扰着我们所有人。我们看到她映在我们经过隔间的电脑显示器上。我们在复印件中看到了她面孔的模糊阴影。她在接待员的预约簿上用铅笔写下她自己，备注是“见巴里·哈克”。她在接待员的语音信箱里留下了信息，这些信息被电话线里的电子啁啾声和嗡嗡声搞得乱七八糟，她的声音在环境嗡嗡声中从遥远的距离回荡。但那是她的声音，在她的声音之下，在静态噪音和嘶嘶声的潮汐声之下，可以听到婴儿的咕哝声和哭声。无论如何，如果你带了午餐，给巴里·哈克多放点东西。我们办公室里有四个巴里。这难道不是巧合吗？
This is the custodian's closet. You have no business to be in the custodian's closet. Kevin Howard sits in that cubicle over there. He is a serial killer, the one they call the Carpet Cutter, responsible for the mutilations across town. We're not supposed to know that, so do not let on. Don't worry. His compulsion inflicts itself only upon strangers, and the routine established is elaborate and unwavering. The victim must be a white male, a young adult no older than 30, heavyset with dark hair and eyes and the like. The victim must be chosen at random, before sunset, from a public place. The victim is followed home and must put up a struggle, et cetera. Kevin Howard does not let any of this interfere with his work. He is, in fact, our fastest typist. He types as if he were on fire. In any case, when Kevin Howard gets caught, act surprised. Say that he seemed like a nice person, a bit of a loner perhaps, but always quiet and polite.
这是清洁工的壁橱。你不应该进清洁工的壁橱。凯文·霍华德坐在那边那个隔间里。他是一个连环杀手，人们称他为“地毯切割者”，对镇上发生的那些肢解案负责。我们不应该知道这一点，所以不要表露出来。别担心。他的强迫冲动只会对陌生人实施，而且所建立的程序非常复杂且坚定不移。受害者必须是白人男性，不超过30岁的年轻成年人，体格魁梧，黑发黑眼之类的。受害者必须在日落前，从公共场所随机挑选。受害者被跟踪回家，必须进行反抗，等等。凯文·霍华德没有让这一切干扰他的工作。事实上，他是我们打字最快的人。他打字的样子就像他着火了一样。无论如何，当凯文·霍华德被抓住时，要表现出惊讶。说他看起来像个好人，也许有点孤僻，但总是安静且有礼貌。
This is the photocopier room, and this, this is our view. It faces southwest. Enjoy this year while photocopying. If you have any problems with the photocopier, see Russell Nash. If you have any questions, ask your supervisor. If you can't find your supervisor, ask Philip Squires. He sits over there. He'll check with Clarissa Nix. She sits there. If you can't find them, feel free to ask for me. This is my cubicle. I sit in there.
这是复印室，这个，这是我们的窗景。它朝向西南。在复印时享受这个景观。如果你在复印机上有任何问题，去找拉塞尔·纳什。如果你有任何问题，问你的主管。如果你找不到你的主管，问菲利普·斯奎尔斯。他坐在那边。他会和克拉丽莎·尼克斯核实。她坐在那里。如果你找不到他们，欢迎来找我。这是我的隔间。我坐在那里面。
Daniel Orozco's story, "Orientation," appears in Best American Short Stories , 1995. At the time it was published, he was making his living as a temp in Seattle, Washington. This story was read by actor Matt Malloy.
丹尼尔·奥罗斯科的故事《入职指导》收录在1995年的《美国最佳短篇小说集》中。在出版时，他靠在华盛顿州西雅图做临时工谋生。这个故事由演员马特·马洛伊朗读。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Peter Clowney, Nancy Updike and Amy Takahara. Contributing editors for this show, Paul Tough, Sarah Vowell, Jack Hitt and Margie Rockland.
好吧，我们今天的节目是由艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔和我自己制作的，还有彼得·克劳尼、南希·厄普代克和艾米·高原。本节目的特约编辑有保罗·塔夫、萨拉·沃威尔、杰克·希特和玛吉·洛克兰。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free or buy tapes. Or you know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even The New York Times all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目或购买磁带。或者你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com上。本节目由国际公共广播电台分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who we love despite his flaws.
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，尽管他有缺陷，我们仍然爱他。
He is a serial killer, the one they call the Carpet Cutter, responsible for the mutilations across town.
他是一个连环杀手，人们称他为“地毯切割者”，对镇上发生的那些肢解案负责。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《这个美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。